[Music]
in carson city and legislators continue in
the special session hello how are you
cheers andrés gonzález with an
informative envelope from the news nao in spanish the
redistribution of snowfall maps
about to be approved however
the debates continue on diversity and if the
river of  nevada says that redistribution will
minimize the latin community that
receives es from las vegas this will be
discussed again today we
could see a final vote
today in atlante that british airways will
begin
non-stop international flights from
mccarran airport that the embryo of
airlines connects las vegas' to
amsterdam as of december 7 that same
day copa airlines returns with its
towns to panama and direct trips to
mexico and canada will begin in
early 2022
and stream back like tuesday now
food cocktails and much more even on
next month you can enjoy the
golden knights on the big screen
carrying the golden knights despite
a long l  Injured player
remains four points behind first
place we are talking about edmón
tonight they will kick off a series of three
games in a row at home this time it will be
against carolina rodrigues at the fort
after all the action starts at
7 pm and now  now we pass
the weather forecast we will be
exceeding 70 degrees by the afternoon
a cold wave is approaching for
southern nevada that will drop temperatures
for the next few days we will stay
in the 60s for the rest of the week
have a nice day done am  andrés
gonzález and this was about the
indignado news in spanish